The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
OCW.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We are talking about jointly
Gaussian random variables.
One comment through all of this
and through all of the
notes is that you can add a
mean to Gaussian random
variables, or you
can talk about
zero-mean random variables.
Here we're using random
variables mostly
to talk about noise.
When we're talking about noise,
you really should be
talking about zero-mean random
variables, because you can
always take the mean out.
And because of that, I don't
like to state everything twice
once for variables of processes
without a mean, and
with a mean.
And after looking at the notes,
I think I've been a
little inconsistent
about that.
I think the point is you can
keep yourself straight by just
saying the only thing
important is the
case without a mean.
Putting the mean in is something
unfortunately done
by people who like complexity.
And they have unfortunately
got in the
notation on their side.
So anytime you want
to talk about a
zero-mean random variable.
You have to say zero-mean
random variable.
And if you say random variable,
it means it could
have a mean or not
have a mean.
And of course the way the
notation should be stated is
you talk about random variables
as things which
don't have means.
And then you can talk about
random variables plus means as
things which do have means,
which would make life easier
but unfortunately it's
not that way.
So anytime you see something
and are wondering about
whether I've been careful about
the mean or not, the
answer is I well might
not have been.
And two, it's not
very important.
So anyway.
Here I'll be talking all
about zero-mean things.
A k-tuple of zero-mean random
variables is said to be
jointly Gaussian if you can
express them in this way here.
Namely as a linear combination
of IID normal Gaussian again
random variables.
OK.
In your homework, those of you
who've done it already, have
realized that just having two
Gaussian random variables is
not enough to make
those two random
variables be jointly Gaussian.
They can be individually
Gaussian
but not jointly Gaussian.
This is sort of important
because when you start
manipulating things as we will
do when we're generating
signals to send and things like
this, you can very easily
wind up with things which look
Gaussian and are appropriately
modeled as Gaussian, but which
are not jointly Gaussian.
Things which are jointly
Gaussian are
defined in this way.
We will come up with
a couple of other
definitions of them later.
But you've undoubtedly been
taught that any old Gaussian
random variables are
jointly Gaussian.
You've probably seen joint
densities for them
and things like this.
Those joint densities only apply
when you have jointly
Gaussian random variables.
And the fundamental definition
is this.
This fundamental definition
makes sense, because the way
that you generate these noise
random variables is usually
from some very large underlying
set of very, very
small random variables.
And the Law of Large Numbers
says that when you add up a
very, very large number of
small underlying random
variables, you normalize the sum
so it has some reasonable
variance then that random
variable is going to be
appropriately modeled
as being Gaussian.
If you at the same time look
at linear combinations of
those things for the same
reason, it's appropriate to
model each of the random
variables you're looking at as
a linear combination of some
underlying set of noise
variables which is
very, very large.
Probably not Gaussian.
But here when we're trying to
do this, because of the
central limit theorem, we just
model these as normal Gaussian
random variables
to start with.
So that's where that definition
comes from.
It's why when you're looking at
noise processes in the real
world, and trying to model them
in a sensible way this
jointly Gaussian is the
thing you almost
always come up with.
OK.
So one important point here, and
the notes point this out.
If each of these random
variables Z sub i is
independent of each of the
others, and they have
arbitrary variances, then
because of this formula, the
set of Z i's are going to
be jointly Gaussian.
Why is that?
Well you simply make a matrix
here A, which is diagonal.
And the elements of this
diagonal matrix are sigma 1
squared, sigma 2 squared, sigma
3 squared, and so forth.
If you have a vector Z, which
is then sigma 1 squared down
to sigma k squared times a noise
vector N1 to N sub k.
What you wind up with is Z sub
i is going to be equal to --
I guess I don't want those
squares in there.
Sigma 1 up to sigma k --
Z sub i is going to be equal to
sigma i, N sub i; N sub i
is a Gaussian random variable
with variance one and
therefore Z sub i as Gaussian
random variable with variance
sigma sub i squared.
OK.
So anyway, one special case of
this formula is anytime that
you want to deal with a set of
independent Gaussian random
variables with arbitrary
variances, they are always
going to be jointly Gaussian.
Saying that they're
uncorrelated is
not enough for that.
You really need the statement
that they're independent of
each other.
OK.
That's sort of where
we were last time.
When you look at this formula,
you can look at it in terms of
sample values.
And if we look at a sample value
what's happening is that
the sample value of the random
vector Z, namely little z, is
going to be defined as some
matrix A times this sample
value for the normal
vector N. OK.
And what we want to look
at is geometrically
what happens there.
Well this matrix a is going to
map a unit vector, E sub i
into the i'th column
of A. Why is that?
Well you look at A, which is
whatever it is, A sub 1, 1,
blah, blah, blah up
to A sub k, k.
And you look at multiplying it
by a vector which is zero only
in the i'th position.
And what's this matrix
multiplication going to do?
It's going to simply pick
out the i'th column
of this matrix here.
OK.
So a is going to map e sub i
into the i'th column of A. OK.
So then the question is what is
this matrix A going to do
to some small cube
in the n plane?
OK.
If you take a small cube in the
n plane from 0 to delta
along the n1 line is going to
map into 0 to this point here,
which is A e sub 1.
This point here is going to
map into A times e sub 2.
This is just drawing for two
dimensions of course.
So in fact all the points in
this cube are going to get map
into this little
rectangle here.
OK.
Namely, that's what a matrix
times a vector is going to do.
Anybody awake out there?
You're all looking at me as
if I'm totally insane.
OK.
Every everyone following this?
So perhaps this is
just too trivial.
I hope not.
OK.
So unit cubes get mapped
into rectangles here.
If I take a unit cube up here,
it's going to get mapped into
the same kind of unit
rectangle here.
If I visualize tiling this plane
here with little tiny
cubes, delta on a side, what's
going to happen?
Each of these little cubes
is going to map into a
parallelogram over here, and
these parallelograms going to
tile this space here.
OK.
Which means that each little
cube here maps into one of
these rectangles.
Each rectangle here maps back
into a little cube here.
Which means that I'm
looking at a very
special case of a here.
I'm looking at a case where
a is non-singular.
In other words, I can get the
any point in this plane by
starting with some point
in this plane.
Which means for any point here,
I can go back here also.
In other words, I can also write
n is equal to A to the
minus 1 times Z. And this
matrix has to exist.
OK.
That's what you mean
geometrically by a
non-singular matrix.
It means that all points in
this plane get mapped into
points in this plane.
And get mapped into only one
point in this plane, and get
mapped into only one point
in this plane.
Where every point in this
plane is the map
of some point here.
In other words you can go
from here to there.
You can also go back again.
OK.
The volume of a parallelepiped
here, and this is in an
arbitrary number of dimensions
is going to be the determinant
of A. And you all know how
to find determinants.
Namely you program a computer
to do it, and the
computer does it.
I mean it used to be we had to
do this by an enormous amount
of calculation.
And of course nobody
does that anymore.
OK.
So we can find the volume of
this parallelepiped, it's this
determinant.
And what does all
of that mean?
Well first let me ask
you the question.
What's going to happen if
the determinant of a
is equaled to zero?
What does that mean
geometrically?
What does that mean here
in terms of this
two dimensional diagram?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Projection
onto a line.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This little cube here is simply
going to get projected
onto some line here.
Like for example that.
In other words it means that
this matrix is not invertible
for one thing, but it also means
everything here gets
mapped onto some lower
dimensional
sub-space here in general.
OK.
Now remember that for a minute,
and we'll come back to
that when we start talking about
probability densities.
OK because of the picture we
were just looking at, the
density of the random variables
Z at A times N,
namely the density of Z at this
particular value here is
just the density that we get
corresponding to the density
of some point here mapped
over into here.
And what's going to happen when
we take a point here and
map it over into here?
If you have a certain amount
of density here, which is
probability per unit volume.
Now when you map it into here,
and the determinant is bigger
than zero, what you're doing
is mapping a little volume
into a big volume.
And if you're doing that over
small enough region where the
probability density is of such
essentially fixed, what's
going to happen to the
probability density over here?
It's going to get scaled down,
and it's going to get scaled
down precisely by that
determinant.
OK.
So what this is saying is the
probability density of the
random variable z, which is
linear combination of these
normal random variables, is in
fact the probability density
of this normal vector N, and we
know what that probability
density is, divided by this
determinant of a.
In fact this is a general
formula for any old
probability density at all.
You can start out with anything
which you call a
random vector N and you can
derive the probability density
of any linear combination
of those elements in
precisely this way.
So long as this volume element
is non-zero, which means
you're not mapping an entire
space into a sub-space.
When you're mapping an entire
space into a sub-space and you
define density as being density
per unit volume, of
course the density in this map
space doesn't exist anymore.
Which is exactly what
this formula says.
If this determinant is zero, it
means this density here is
going to be infinite in the
regions where this z exists at
all, which is just in this
linear sub-space, and what do
you do about that?
I mean do you get all
frustrated about it?
Or do you say what's going
on and treat it in
some sensible way?
I mean the thing is
happening here.
And this talks about
it a little bit.
If a is singular, then
A is going to map Rk
into a proper sub-space.
Determinant A is going
to be equal to 0.
The density doesn't exist.
So what do you do about it?
I mean what does this mean
if you're mapping
into a smaller sub-space.
What does it mean in terms
of this diagram here?
Well in the diagram here
it's pretty clear.
Because these little cubes here
are getting mapped into
straight lines here.
Yeah?
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Some linear
combinations of this are being
mapped into 0.
Namely if this straight line
is this way any Z which is
going in this direction is
being mapped into 0.
Any vector Z which is going in
this direction has to be
identically equaled to 0.
In other words some linear
combination of n1 and n2 is a
random variable which takes on
the value 0 identically.
Why do you try to represent that
in a probabilistic sense?
Why don't you just take it out
of consideration altogether?
Here what it means is that z1
and z2 are simply linear
combinations of each other.
OK.
In other words once you know
what the sample value of z1
is, you can find the
sample values z2.
In other words z2 is a linear
combination of z1.
It's linearly dependent on z1,
which means that you can
identify it exactly once
you know what z1 is.
Which means you might as
well not call it a
random variable at all.
Which means you might as well
view this situation where the
determinant is 0 as where the
vector Z is really just one
random variable, and everything
else is determined.
So you throw out these extra
random variables,
pseudo-random variables, which
are really just linear
combinations of the others.
So you deal with a smaller
dimensional set.
You find the probability
density of the smaller
dimensional set, and you don't
worry about all of these
mathematical peculiarities that
would arise otherwise.
OK.
So once we do that, A is going
to be non-singular.
Because we're going to be left
with a set of random
variables, which are
not linearly
dependent on each other.
They can be statistically
dependent on each other, but
not linearly dependent, OK.
So for all z then, since
determinant A is not 0, the
probability density at some
arbitrary vector Z is going to
be the normal joint density
evaluated at a to the minus 1z
divided by the determinant
of A. OK.
In other words we're just
working the map backwards.
This formula is the same as this
formula, except instead
of writing An here, we're
writing z here.
And when An is equal to z then
little n has to be equal to A
to the minus 1z.
And what does that say?
It says that the joint
probability density has to be
equal to this quantity here.
Which in matrix terms looks
rather simple, it
looks rather nice.
You can rewrite this.
This is a norm here,
so it's this vector
there times this vector.
Where in fact when you want to
multiply vectors in this way,
you're taking inner product of
the vector with this cell.
These are real vectors
we're looking at.
Because we're trying to model
real noise, because we're
modeling the noise on
communication channels.
So this is going to be the
inner product of A to the
minus 1z with itself, which
means you want to look at the
transform of a to
the minus 1z.
Now what's the transform
of a to the minus 1z?
It's z transform times a to
the minus 1 transform.
So we wind up with a to the
minus 1 transform times a to
the minus 1 times z.
So we have some kind of peculiar
bilinear form here.
So for any sample value of the
random vector Z we can find
the probability density in terms
of this quantity here.
Which looks a little bit
peculiar, but it
doesn't look too bad.
OK.
Now we want to simplify
that a little bit.
Anytime you're dealing with
zero-mean random variables --
now remember I'm going to forget
to say zero-mean half
the time because everything is
concerned with zero-mean
random variables.
The covariance of Z1 and Z2 is
expected value of Z1 times Z2.
So if you have a k-tuple Z,
the covariance is a matrix
whose i,j element is expected
value of Zi times Zj.
And what that means is that the
covariance matrix, this is
a matrix now, it's going to be
the expected value of z times
z transpose.
Z is a random vector, which is
a column random vector, Z
transpose is a row-random
vector, which is this simply
turned upside down, turned
by 90 degrees.
Now when you multiply the
components of this vector
together, you can see that what
you get is the elements
of this covariance matrix.
In other words this is just
standard matrix manipulation,
which I hope most of you or at
least partly familiar with.
OK.
When we then talk about the
expected values Z times Z
transpose we can write this as
the expected value of A times
N, which is what z is.
N transpose times A transpose,
which is what Z transpose is.
And miraculously here the N and
the N transpose are in the
middle here, where it's easy
to deal with them, because
these are normal Gaussian
random variables.
And when you look at this column
times this row, since
all diagonal elements are
independent of each other, and
all of them have variance one,
the expected value of N times
N transpose is simply
the identity matrix.
All the randomness goes out of
this which it obviously has to
because we're looking at a
covariance which is just a
matrix and not something
random.
So you wind up with this
covariance matrix is equal to
a rather arbitrary matrix A,
but not singular, times the
transpose of that matrix.
OK.
We've assumed that A is
non-singular and therefore
it's not too hard to see the k
sub Z is non-singular also.
And explicitly case of Z mainly
its co-variance matrix,
the inverse of it, is A to the
minus 1 transpose times A to
the minus 1.
Namely you take the inverse and
you start flipping things
and you do all of these
neat matrix things
that you always do.
And you should review them
if you've forgotten that.
So that when we write our
probability density, which was
this in terms of this
transformation here, what we
get is the density of Z is
equal to, in place of
determinant of A, we get the
square root of the determinant
in the k sub Z. You probably
don't remember that, but is
what you get.
And it's sort of a blah.
Here this is more interesting.
This is minus 1/2 z transpose
times Kz to the
minus 1 times z.
What does this tell you?
Look at this formula.
Is it just a big formula or
what does it say to you?
You got to look at these things
and see what they say.
I mean we've gone through
a lot of work to derive
something here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well it
is Gaussian.
Yes.
I mean that's the way we define
jointly Gaussian.
But what's the funny
thing about
this probability density?
What does it depend on?
What do I have to tell you in
order for you to calculate
this probability density
for every z you
want to plug in here?
I have to tell you what this
covariance matrix is.
And once I tell you what the
covariance matrix is, there is
nothing more to be specified.
In other words, a jointly
Gaussian random vector is
completely specified by
its covariance matrix.
And it's specified exactly
this way by
its covariance matrix.
OK.
There's nothing more there.
So this says anytime you're
dealing with jointly Gaussian,
the only thing you have to
be interested in is this
covariance here.
Namely all you need to have
jointly Gaussian is somebody
has to tell you what the
covariance is, and somebody
has to tell you also that
it's jointly Gaussian.
Jointly Gaussian plus a given
covariance specifies the
probability density.
OK.
What does that tell you?
Well let's look at an example
where we just have two random
variables, Z1 and Z2.
then expected value of Z1
squared is the upper.
Left hand element of that
covariance matrix, which we'll
call sigma 1 squared.
The lower, right hand side of
the matrix is K22, which we'll
call sigma 2 squared.
And we're going to let rho be
the normalize covariance.
We're just defining a bunch of
things here, because this is
the way people usually
define this.
So rho will be the normalized
cross covariance.
Then the determinant of the
Kz is this mess here.
For A to be non-singular, we
have to have rho less than 1.
If rho is equal to 1 then this
determinant is going to be
equal to 0, and we're back in
this awful case that we don't
want to think about.
So then if we go through the
trouble of finding out what
the inverse of K sub z is, we
find this 1 over 1 minus row
square times this matrix here.
The probability density plugging
this in is this big
thing here.
OK what does that tell you?
Well the thing that it tells
me is that I never want to
deal with this, and I
particularly don't want to
deal with it if I'm dealing with
three or more variables.
OK.
In other words the interesting
thing here is the simple
formula we had before, which
is this formula.
OK.
And we have computers these
days which say given nice
formulas like this, their
standard computer routines to
calculate things like this.
And you never want to look at
some awful mess like this.
OK.
And if you put a mean into here,
which you will see in
every textbook on random
variables and probability you
ever look at, this thing becomes
so ugly that you were
probably convinced before you
took this class that jointly
Gaussian random variables were
things you wanted to avoid
like the plague.
And if you really have to deal
with explicit formulas like
this, you're absolutely right.
You do want to avoid them like
the plague, because you can't
get any insight from what that
says, or at least I can't.
So I say OK, we have
to deal with this.
But yet we like to get a little
more insight about what
this means.
And to do this, we like to find
a little bit more about
what these bilinear forms
are all about.
Those of you who have taken any
course on linear algebra
have dealt with these
bilinear forms.
And played with them forever.
And those of you who haven't are
probably puzzled about how
to deal with them.
The notes have an appendix,
which is about two pages long
which tells you what you have to
know about these matrices.
And I will just sort of quote
those results as we go.
Incidentally those results
are not hard to derive.
And not hard to find
out about.
You can simply derive them on
your own, or you can look at
Strang's book on linear algebra,
which is about the
simplest way to get them.
And that's all you need to do.
OK.
We've said the probability
density depends on this
bilinear form z transpose
times Kz to the
minus 1 time z.
What is this?
Is this a matrix or
a vector or what?
How many people think
it's a matrix?
it's a vector?
You think it's a vector?
OK.
Well in a very peculiar
sense it is.
How many people think
it's a number?
Good.
OK.
It is a number, and it's
a number because
this is a row vector.
This is a matrix.
This is a column vector.
And if you think of multiplying
a matrix times a
column vector, you get
a column vector.
And if you take a row vector
times a column
vector, you got a number.
OK.
So this is just a number which
depends on little z.
OK.
Kz is called a positive
definite matrix.
And it's called a positive
definite matrix, because this
thing is always non-negative.
And it always has to be
non-negative because this
refers to the --
if I put capital Z in here,
namely if I put the random
vector in here Z, then what this
is, is the variance of a
particular random variable.
So it has to be greater
than or equal to zero.
So anyway K sub z is always
non-negative definite.
Here it's going to be positive
definite, because we've
already assumed that the matrix
A was non-singular, and
therefore the matrix Kz has
to be non-singular.
So this has to be positive
definite.
So it has an inverse, K sub
z minus 1 is also positive
definite which means this
quantity is always greater
than zero, if z is non-zero.
You can take these positive
definite matrices and you can
find eigenvectors and
eigenvalues for them.
Do you ever actually calculate
these eigenvectors and
eigenvalues?
I hope not.
It's a mess to do it.
I mean it's just as bad as
writing that awful formula we
had before.
So you don't want to actually do
this, but it's nice to know
that these things exist.
And because these vectors exist,
and in fact if you have
a matrix which is k by k, little
k by little k, then
there are k such eigenvectors
and they can be chosen
orthonormal.
OK.
In other words each of these Q
sub i are orthogonal to each
of the others.
You can clearly scale them,
because you scale this and
scale this together.
And it's going to maintain
equality.
So you just scale them down so
you can make them normalize.
If you have a bunch of
eigenvectors with the same
eigenvalue, then the whole
linear sub-space formed by
that set of eigenvectors all
have the same eigenvalue
lambda sub i.
Namely you take any linear
combination of these things
which satisfy this equation
for a particular lambda.
And any linear combination
will satisfy the
same the same equation.
So you can simply choose an
orthonormal set among them to
satisfy this.
And if you look at Q sub i and
Q sub j, which have different
eigenvalues, then it's pretty
easy to show that in fact they
have to be orthogonal
to each other.
So anyway when you do this you
wind up with this form becomes
just the sum over i of lambda
sub i to the minus 1.
Namely these eigenvalues
to the minus 1.
These eigenvalues are
all positive.
Times the inner product
of z with Q sub i.
In other words, you take
whatever vector Z you're
interested in here, you
project it on these k
orthonormal vectors Q sub i.
You get those k values.
And then this form here is
just that sum there.
So when you write
the probability
density in that way --
we still have this here
we'll get rid of that
in the minute --
you have e to the minus sum over
i, these inner product
terms squared divided by
2 times lambda sub i.
That's just because this
is equal to this.
It's just substituting this for
this in the formula for
the probability density.
OK.
What does that say
pictorially?
Let me show you a picture
of it first.
It says that for any positive
definite matrix and therefore
for any covariance matrix,
you can always find these
orthonormal vectors.
I've drawn them here
for two dimensions.
They're just some arbitrary
vector q1; q2 has to be
orthogonal to it.
And if you look at the square
root of lambda 1 times q1, you
got a point here.
You look at the square root of
lambda 2 times q2, you got a
point here.
If you then look at this
probability density here, you
see that all the points on this
ellipse here have to have
the same sum of z
times Q sub i.
OK.
It looked a little
better over here.
Yes.
OK.
Namely the points little z for
which this is constant are the
points which form
this ellipse.
And it's the ellipse which has
the axes square root of lambda
i times Q sub i.
And then you just imagine it
if it's lined up this way.
And think of what you would get
if you were looking at the
lines of equal probability
density for independent
Gaussian random variables with
different variances.
I mean we already pointed out
if the variances are all the
same, these equal probability
contours are spheres.
If you now expand on some of
the axes, you get ellipses.
And now we've taken these
arbitrary vectors, so these
are not in the directions we
started out with, but in some
arbitrary directions.
We have q1 and q2 are
orthornormal to each other,
because that's the way
we've chosen them.
And then the probability
density has this form
which is this form.
And the other thing we can do is
to take this form here and
say gee this is just a
probability density for a
bunch of independent random
variables, where the
independent random variables are
the inner product of the
random vector Z with Q sub 1 up
to the inner product of z
with Q sub k.
So these are independent
Gaussian random variables.
They have variances
lambda sub i.
And this is the nicest formula
for the probability density of
an arbitrary set of jointly
density of jointly Gaussian
random variables.
OK.
In other words what this says
is in general if you have a
set of jointly Gaussian random
variables and I have this
messy form here, all you're
doing is looking at them in a
wrong coordinate system.
If you switch them around, you
look at them this way instead
of this way, you're going to
have independent Gaussian
random variables.
And the way to look at them
is found by solving this
eigenvector eigenvalue equation,
which will tell you
what these orthogonal
directions are.
And then it'll tell you how to
get this nice picture that
looks this way.
OK.
OK so that tells us what we
need to know, maybe even a
little more than we have to
know, about jointly Gaussian
random variables.
But there's one more
bonus we get.
And the bonus is
the following.
If you create a matrix here B
where the i'th row of B is
this vector Q sub i divided by
the square root of lambda sub
i, then what this is going to
do is the corresponding
element here is going to be a
normalized Gaussian random
variable with variance one and
all of these are going to be
independent of each other.
OK.
That's essentially what
we were saying before.
This is just another way of
saying the same thing.
That when you squish this
probability density around and
look at it in a different frame
of reference, and then
you scale the random variables
down or up, what you wind up
with is IID normal Gaussian
random variables.
OK.
But that says that Z is
equal to B to the
minus 1 times N prime.
Well so what?
Here's the reason for so what.
We started out with a definition
of jointly
Gaussian, which is probably not
the definition of jointly
Gaussian you've ever seen if
you've seen this before.
Then what we did was to say,
OK if you have jointly
Gaussian random variables
and they're not linearly
independent and none of them are
linearly dependent on the
others, then this matrix
A is invertible.
From that we derive the
probability density.
From the probability density
we derive this.
OK.
The only thing you need
to get this is
the probability density.
And this says that anytime you
have a random vector Z with
this probability density that
we just wrote down.
Then you have the property that
N prime is equal to BZ,
and Z is equal to B to
the minus 1 N prime.
Which says that if you have this
probability density, then
you have jointly Gaussian
random variables.
So we have an alternate
definition of jointly Gaussian.
Random variables are jointly
Gaussian if they have this
probability density.
You can somehow represent them
as linear combinations of
normal random variables.
OK.
Then there's something
even simpler.
It says that if all linear
combinations of a random
vector Z are Gaussian, then
Z is jointly Gaussian.
Why is that?
well If you look at this formula
here, it says take any
old random vector at all that
has a covariance matrix.
From that covariance matrix, we
can solve for all of these
eigenvectors.
If I find the appropriate random
variables here from
this transformation, those
random variables are then
uncorrelated from each other,
they are all statistically
independent of each other, And
it follows from that, that if
all these linear combinations
are Gaussian then Z has to be
jointly Gaussian.
OK.
So we now have three
definitions.
This one is the simplest
one to state.
It's the hardest one
to work with.
That's life you know.
This one is probably the most
straightforward, because you
don't have to know anything to
understand this definition.
This original definition is
physically the most appealing
because it shows why noise
vectors actually
do have this property.
OK.
So here's a summary
of all of this.
It says if Kz is singular, you
want to remove the linearly
independent random variables.
You just take them away because
they're uniquely
specified in terms of
the other variables.
And then you take the resulting
non-singular matrix,
and Z is going to be jointly
Gaussian if and only if Z is
equal to AN for some normal
random variable N. If Z has
jointly Gaussian density or if
all linear combinations of Z
are Gaussian all of this for 0
mean would mean it applies to
fluctuation.
OK.
So why do we have to know all of
that about jointly Gaussian
random variables?
Well because everything about
Gaussian processes depends on
jointly Gaussian random
variables.
You can't do anything with
Gaussian processes without
being able to look
at these jointly
Gaussian random variables.
And the reason is that we said
that Z of t is a Gaussian
process if for every k and every
set of time instance,
every set of e, that's
t1 to t sub k.
If Z of t1 up to Z of
tk is a jointly
Gaussian random vector.
OK.
So that directly links the
definition of a Gaussian
process to Gaussian
random vectors.
OK.
Supposed the sample functions
of Z of t or L2 with
probability one.
I want to say a little bit about
this because otherwise
you can't sort out any of these
things about how L2
theory connects with
random processes.
OK.
So I'm going to start out by
just assuming that all these
sample functions are going
to be L2 functions with
probability 1.
One way to ensure this is to
look only at processes of the
form Z of t equals some sum
of Z sub i times ti of t.
OK remember at the beginning
we started looking at this
process the sum of a set of
normalized Gaussian random
variables times sinc
functions times
displaced sinc functions.
You can also do the same
thing with Fourier
coefficients or anything.
You got a fairly general set
of processes that way.
unfortunately they don't quite
work, because if you look at
the sinc functions and you
look at noise, which is
independent and identically
distributed in time, then the
sample functions are going
to have infinite energy.
I mean that kind of process
just runs on forever.
It runs on with finite
power forever.
And therefore it has
infinite energy.
And therefore the simplest
process to look at, the sample
functions are non-L2 with
probability one, which is sort
of unfortunate.
So we say OK we don't care about
that, because if you
want to look at that process
a sum of Z sub i times sinc
functions, what do
you care about?
I mean you only care about the
terms in that expansion, which
run from the big bang until
the next big bang.
OK.
We certainly don't care about it
before that or after that.
And if we look within those
finite time limits, then all
these functions are
going to be L2.
Because they just last for
a finite amount of time.
So all we need to do is to
truncate these things somehow.
And we're going to diddle around
a little bit with a
question of how to truncate
these series.
But for the time being we
just say we can do that.
And we will do it.
So we can look at any processes
the form sum of Zi
times phi i of t, where the Zi
are independent and the phi i
of t are orthonormal.
And to make things L2, we're
going to assume that the sum
over i of Zi squared bar
is less than infinity.
OK.
In other words we only take a
finite number of these things,
or if we want to take infinite
a number of them, the
variances are going
to go off to zero.
And I don't know whether you're
proving it in the
homework this time or you will
prove it in the homework next
time, I forget, but you're going
to look at the question
of why this finite variance
condition makes these sample
functions be L2 with
probability one.
OK.
So if you had this condition,
then all your sample functions
are going to be L2.
I'm going to get off
all of this L2
business relatively shortly.
I want to do a little bit
of it to start with.
Because if any of you have start
doing any research in
this area, at some point you're
going to be merrily
working away calculating
all sorts of things.
And suddenly you're going to
find that none of it exists,
because of these problems
of infinite energy.
And you're going to
get very puzzled.
So one of the things I tried to
do in the notes is to write
them in way that you can
understand them at a first
reading without worrying
about any of this.
And then when you go back for a
second reading, you can pick
up all the mathematics
that you need.
So that in fact you won't have
the problem of suddenly
finding out that three-quarters
of your thesis
has to be thrown away, because
you've been dealing with
things that don't
make any sense.
OK.
So, we're going to define linear
functionals in the
following way.
We're going to first look at the
sample functions of this
random process Z. OK.
Now we talked about
this last time.
If you have a random process Z
than really what you have is a
set of functions defined
on some samples space.
So the quantities you're
interested in is what is the
value of the random process at
time t for sample point omega.
OK.
If we look at that and make it
for a given omega, this thing
becomes a function of t.
In fact for a given omega, this
is just what we've been
calling a sample element
of the random process.
So if we take this sample
element, look at the inner
product of that with some
function g of t.
In other words we look at the
integral of Z of t omega times
g of t, dt.
And if all these sample
functions are L2 and if g of t
is L2, what happens when you
take the integral of an L2
function times an L2 function,
which is the inner product of
something L2 with something L2
which says something with
finite energy inner
product with
something with finite energy.
Well the Schwarz inequality
tells you that if this has
finite energy and this has
finite energy, the inner
product exists.
That's the reason why we went
through the Schwarz
inequality.
It's the main reason
for doing that.
So these things have
finite value.
So V of omega the results of
doing this namely V as a
function of the sample space
is a real number.
And it's a real number for the
sample points of omega with
probability one, which means
we can talk about V as a
random variable.
OK.
And now V is a random variable
which is defined in this way.
And from now on we will call
these things linear
functionals which are in fact
the integral of a random
process times a function.
And we can take that
kind of integral.
It sort of looks like the linear
combinations of things
we were doing before when we
were talking about matrices
and random vectors.
OK.
If we restrict the random
process to have the following
form, where these are
independent and these are
orthonormal, then one of these
linear functionals is given by
the random variable V is going
to be the integral of Z of t
times g of t, but
Z of t is this.
And at this point we're not
going to fuss about
interchanging integrals
with summations.
You have the machinery to do it,
because we're now dealing
with an L2 space.
We're not going to
fuss about it.
And I advise you not
to fuss about it.
So we have a sum of these random
variables here times
these integrals here.
These integrals here are just
projections of g of t on this
space of orthonormal
functions.
So whatever space of orthonormal
functions gives
you your jollies, use it talk
about the inner products on
that space.
This gives you a nice inner
products space of
sequences of numbers.
And then if the z i are jointly
Gaussian, then V is
going to be Gaussian.
And then to generalize this one
little bit further, if you
take a whole bunch of L2
functions, g1 of t g2 of t and
so forth, you can talk about
a whole bunch of random
variables V1 up to V sub j, 0.
And V sub j is going to be
the integral of Z of
t times gj of tdt.
Remember this thing
looks very simple.
It looks like the --
like the convolutions you've
been doing all your life.
It's not.
It's really a rather
peculiar quantity.
This in fact is what we call a
linear functional, and is the
integral of a random
process times this.
Which we have defined in terms
of the sample functions of the
random process.
And now we said OK now that we
understand what it is, we will
just write this all the time.
But I just caution
you not to let
familiarity breed contempt.
Because this is a rather
peculiar notion.
And a rather powerful notion.
OK.
So these things are
jointly Gaussian.
We want to take the expected
value of V sub i times V sub
j, and now we're going to do
this without worrying about
being careful at all.
We have the expected value of
the integral of Z of t, gi of
t, td times the integral of
Z tau gj of tau, d tau.
And now we're going to slide
this expected value inside of
both of these integrals.
And not worry about it.
And therefore what we're going
to have is a double integral
of gi of t expected value of z
of t time z of tau times gj of
tau dt, d tau, which
is this thing here.
Which you should compare with
what we've been dealing with
most of the lecture today.
This is the same kind of form
for a covariance function as
we've been dealing with for
covariance matrices.
It has very similar effects.
I mean before you were just
talking about finite
dimensional matrices, which is
all simple mathematically in
eigenfunctions and
eigenvalues.
You have eigenfunctions
and eigenvalues of
these things also.
And so long as these are defined
nicely by these L2
properties we've been
talking about.
In fact you can deal with these
in virtually the same
way that you can deal with
the matrices we were
dealing with before.
If you just remember what the
results are from matrices, you
can guess what they are for
these covariance functions.
OK.
But anyway you can find the
expected value of Vi times Vj
by this formula.
Again we're dealing with
zero-mean and therefore we
don't have to worry about the
mean, put that in later.
And that all exists.
OK.
So the next thing we want
to deal with, hitting
you with a lot today.
But I mean the trouble is a lot
of this is half familiar
to most of you.
People who have taken various
communication courses at
various places have all been
exposed to random processes in
some highly trivialized sense.
But the major results are the
same as the results we're
going through here.
And all we're doing here is
adding a little bit of
carefulness about what works
and what doesn't work.
Incidentally in the notes which
is towards the end of
lectures 14 and 15, we give
three examples which let you
know why in fact we want to
look primarily at random
processes which are defined in
terms of a sum of independent
Gaussian random variables time
orthonormal functions.
And if you look at those
three examples, some
of them have problems.
Because of the fact that
everything you're dealing with
has infinite energy.
And therefore it doesn't
really make any sense.
And one of them I should
talk about this just a
little bit in class.
And I think I still have a
couple of minutes, is a very
strange process where
Z of t is IID.
In fact just let it be normal.
And independent for all t.
OK.
In other words you generate a
random process by looking at
an uncountably infinite
collection of
normal random variables.
How do you deal with
such a process?
I don't know how to
deal with it.
I mean it sounds like
it's simple.
If I put this on a quiz,
three-quarters of you would
say oh that's very simple.
What we're dealing with is a
family of impulse functions.
Spaced arbitrarily
closely together.
This is not impulse function.
Impulse functions are even worse
than this, but this is
bad enough.
When we start talking about
spectral density, we can
explain this a little bit better
by thinking this kind
of process it doesn't
make any sense.
But this kind of process, if
you look at its spectral
density, it's going to have a
spectral density which is zero
everywhere, but whose integral
over all frequencies is one.
OK.
In other words it's not
something you want to wish on
your on your worse friend.
It makes a certain amount of
sense as a limit of things.
You can look at a very broadband
process where in
fact you spread the process
out enormously.
You can make pseudo noise which
looks sort of like this.
And you make the process broader
and broader and lower
and lower intensity
everywhere.
But it still has this
energy of one.
It still has a power
of one everywhere.
And it just is ugly.
OK.
Now if you never worried about
these questions of L2, you
would look at a process like
that and say, gee there must
be some easy way to handle that
because it's probably the
easiest process you
can define.
I mean everything is normal.
If you look at any set at
different times, you get a set
of IID normal Gaussian
variables.
You try to put it together, and
it doesn't mean anything.
If you pass it through a filter,
the filter is going to
cancel it all out.
So anyway, that's one reason
why we want to look at this
restricted class of random
processes we're looking at.
OK.
What we're interested in now is
we want to take a Gaussian
random process really, but you
can take any random process.
We want to pass it through a
filter, and we want to look at
the random process
that comes out.
OK.
And that certainly is a very
physical kind of operation.
I mean any kind of communication
system that you
build is going to have
noise on the channel.
And one of the first things
you're going to do is you're
going to filter what
you've received.
So you have to have some way
of dealing with this.
OK.
And the way we sort of been
dealing with it all along in
terms of the transmitted way
forms we've been dealing with
is to say OK.
What we're going to do is to
first look what happens when
we take sample functions of
this, pass them through the
filter, and then what comes
out is going to be some
function again.
And then we're back into
what you studied as an
undergraduate talking about
functions through filters.
We're going to jazz it up a
little bit by saying these
functions are going to
be L2 the filters
are going to be L2.
So that in fact you know
you'd get something
out that make sense.
So what we're doing is looking
at these sample functions V
the output at time tau for
sample point omega is going to
be the convolution of the input
at time t and sample
point omega.
Remember this one sample point
exists for all time.
That's why these sample points
and sample spaces are so damn
complicated.
Because they have everything
in them.
OK.
So there's one sample point
which exists for all of them.
This is a sample function.
You're passing the sample
function through a filter,
which is just normal
convolution.
What comes out then.
If in fact we express this
random process in terms of
this orthonormal sum the way
we've been doing before.
Is you get the sum over j of
this, which is a sample value
of the j'th random variable
coming out times the integral
of pj of t, h of tau
minus t, d tau.
OK.
For each tau that you look at,
this is just a sample value of
a linear functional.
OK.
If I want to look at this at one
value of tau, I have this
integral here which is
a random process.
A sample value of a
random process at
omega time a function.
This is just a function
of t for given tau.
OK.
So this is a linear
functional.
As a type we've been
talking about.
And that linear functional
is then given by
this for each tau.
This is a sample value
of a linear
functional we can talk about.
OK.
These things are then, if you
look over the whole sample
space omega, V of tau becomes
a random variable.
OK.
V of tau is the random variable
whose sample values
are V of t omega, and they're
given by this.
So if z of t is Gaussian
process, you get jointly
Gaussian linear functionals at
each of any set of times tau
1, tau 2 up to tau sub k.
So this just gives you a whole
set of linear functionals.
And if z of t is a Gaussian
process, then all these linear
functionals are going to be
jointly Gaussian also.
And bingo.
What we have then is an
alternate way to generate
Gaussian processes.
OK.
In other words you can generate
a Gaussian process by
specifying at each set of k
times, you have jointly
Gaussian random variables.
But once you do that, once you
understand one Gaussian
process, you're off
and running.
Because then you can pass
it through any L2 filter
that you want to.
And you generate another
Gaussian process.
So for example, if you start
out with this sinc type
process, I mean we'll see that
that has a spectral density,
which is flat over
all frequencies.
And we'll talk about spectral
density tomorrow.
But then you pass it through a
linear filter, and you can
give it any spectral density
that you want.
So at this point, we really
have enough to talk about
arbitrary covariance functions
just by starting out with
random processes, which are
defined in terms of some
sequence of orthonormal
random variables.
OK.
Now we can get to covariance
function of a filter process
in the same way as we got the
matrix for linear functionals.
OK.
And this is just computation.
So what is it?
The covariance function of
this output process V
evaluated at one time
r another time s.
One of the nasty things about
notation when you start
dealing with a covariance
function of the input and the
output to a linear filter is
you suddenly need to worry
about two times at the
input and two other
times at the output.
OK.
Because this thing is then
expected value of V sub r
times the expected
value of V subs.
OK.
This is a random variable, which
is the process V of r
evaluated at time r.
This is the random variable,
which is the process V of t
evaluated at a particular
time s.
This is going to be the expected
value of what this
random variable now is the
integral of the random process
z of t times this function
here, which is now
a function of t.
Because we're looking at
a fixed value of r.
So this is a linear functional,
which is a random variable.
This is another linear
functional.
This is evaluated at some time
s, which is the output of the
filter at time s.
Then we will throw caution to
the wind interchange integrals
with expectation
and everything.
And then in the middle we'll
have expected value of z of t
times z of tau, which is the
covariance function of z.
OK.
So the covariance function of
z then specifies what the
covariance function
of the output is.
OK.
So whenever you pass a random
process through a filter if
you know what the covariance
function of input to the
filter is, you can find the
covariance function of the
output of the filter.
That's a kind of a nasty
formula, it's not very nice.
But anyway the thing that it
tells you is that whether this
random process is
Gaussian or not.
The only thing that determines
the covariance function of the
output of the filter is the
covariance function of the
input to the filter plus of
course the filter response,
which is needed OK.
And this is just the same kind
of bilinear form that we were
dealing with before.
Next time we will talk a little
bit about the fact that
when you're dealing with a
bilinear form like this, you
can take these covariance
functions and they have the
same kind of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors that we had
before for a matrix.
Namely this is again going to
be positive definite as a
function, and we will be able
to find its eigenvectors and
its eigenvalues.
We can't calculate them.
Computers can calculate them.
People who've spend their
lives doing this
can calculate them.
I wouldn't suggest that you
spend your life doing this.
Because again you would be
setting yourself up as a
second class computer, and
you don't make any
profit out of that.
But anyway, we can find this
in principle from this.
OK.
One of the things that we
haven't talked about at all
yet, and which we will start
talking about next time in
which the next set of lecture
notes, lecture 16, we'll deal
with is the question
of stationarity.
Let me say just a little bit
about that to get into it.
And then we'll talk a lot
more about it next time.
The notes will probably be on
the web some time tomorrow.
I hope before noon if you
want to look at them.
Physically if you look at a
stochastic process, and you
want to model it.
I mean suppose you want to
model a noise process.
How do you model a
noise process?
Well you look at it over
a long period of time.
You start taking statistics
about it over a
long period of time.
And somehow you want to model
it in such a way, I mean the
only thing you can look at
is statistics over a
long period of time.
So if you're only looking at one
process, you can look at
it for a year and then you can
model it, and then you can use
that model for the
next 10 years.
And what that's assuming is that
the noise process looks
the same way this year
as it does next year.
You can go further than that
and say, OK I'm going to
manufacture cell phones or some
other kind of widget.
And what I'm interested in then
is what these noise wave
forms are to the whole
collection of my widgets.
Namely different people
will buy my widgets.
They will use them in
different places.
So I'm interested in modeling
the noise over this whole set
of widgets.
But still if you're doing that
you're still almost forced to
deal with models which have the
same statistics over at
least a broad range of times.
Sometimes when we're dealing
with wireless communication we
say, no the channel keeps
changing in time. and the
channel keeps changing
slowly in time.
And therefore you don't have
the same statistics
now as you have then.
If you want to understands that,
believe me, the only way
you're going to understand it is
to first understand how to
deal with statistics for
the channel which
stay the same forever.
And once you understand those
statistics, you will then be
in a position to start to
understand what happens when
these statistics
change slowly.
OK.
In other words, what our
modeling assumption is in this
course, and I believe it's the
right modeling assumption for
all engineers, is that you never
start with some physical
phenomena and say, I want to
test the hell out of this
until I find an appropriate
statistical model for it.
You do that only after
you know enough
about random processes.
That you know how to deal with
an enormous variety of
different home cooked
random processes.
OK.
So what we do in a course like
this is we deal with lots of
different home cooked random
processes, which is in fact
why we've done rather peculiar
things like saying, let's look
at a random process which
comes from a sum of
independent random variables
multiplied
by orthonormal functions.
And you see what we've
accomplished by that already.
Namely by starting out that way
we've been able to define
Gaussian processes.
We've been able to define what
happens when one of those
Gaussian processes goes
through a filter.
And in fact, that gives a way
of generating a lot more
random processes.
And next time what we're going
to do is not to say how is it
that we know that processes
are stationary.
How do you test whether
processes are
stationary or not.
But we're just going to assume
that they're stationary.
In other words if they had the
same statistics now as they're
going to have next year.
And those statistics stay
the same forever.
And then see what we
can say about it.
To give you a clue as to how
to start looking at this,
remember what we said quite
a long time ago
about Markov chains.
OK.
And now when you look at Markov
chains, remember that
what happens at one time is
statistically a function of
what happened at the unit
of time before it.
OK.
But we can still model those
Markov change as being
stationary.
Because the dependents at this
time on the previous sample of
time is the same now as it will
be five years from now.
OK.
In other words you can't just
look at the process at one
instant of time and say
this is independent
of all other times.
That's not what stationary
means.
What stationary means is the way
the process depends on the
past at time t is the same is
the way it depends on the past
at some later time tau.
And that in fact is the way
we're going to define
stationarity.
It's at these joint sample times
that we're going to be
looking at.
Which I had a better
word for that.
Join sets of epochs that
we'll be looking at.
The joint statistics over a set
of epics is going to be
the same now as it will be at
sometime in the future.
And that's the way we're going
to define stationarity.
A prelude of what we're going
to find when we do that is
that this covariance function,
if the covariance function at
time t and time tau is the same
if you translate it up to
t plus t1 and tau plus t1, then
in fact this function is
going to be a function only if
the difference t minus tau.
It's going to be a function
of one variable
instead of two variables.
OK.
So as soon as we get this
function being a function of
one variable instead of two
variables, first thing we're
going to do is to take the
Fourier transform of this.
Because then we'll be taking
the Fourier transform of a
function of a single variable.
We're going to call
that the spectral
density of the process.
And we're going to find that for
stationary processes the
spectrum densities tell you
everything if they're Gaussian.
Why is that?
Well the inverse Fourier
transform is
this covariance function.
And we've now seen that the
covariance function tells you
everything about a
Gaussian process.
So if you know the spectral
density for a stationary
process, it will tell
you everything.
We will also have to fiddle
around a little bit about how
we define stationarity.
But at the same time
don't have this
infinite energy problem.
And the way we're going
to do it is the way
we've done it all along.
We're going to take something
that looked stationary, we're
going to truncate it over some
long period of time, and we're
going to have our cake and
eat it too that way.
OK.
So we'll do that next time.